I think one thing we should have learned
from the 20th century,
but of course didn't was that there is
something extraordinary dangerous about
totalitarian utopian visions at
something Dostoevsky wrote about,
by the way,
in his great book notes from underground
because Dostoevsky had figured out by
the early 19 hundreds that there was
something very,
very pathological about a utopian vision
of perfection,
that it was profoundly anti human and
and notes and notes from underground.
He demolishes the notion of Utopia.
One of the things he says that I loved,
it's so brilliant,
he said,
imagine that you brought the socialist
utopia into being and dusty FCC says
that human beings had nothing to do
except
eat,
drink,
and busy themselves with the
continuation of the species.
He said that the first thing that would
happen under circumstances like that
would be that human beings would go mad
and break the system,
smash it just so that something
unexpected and crazy could happen
because human beings don't want Utopian
comfort and certainty.
They want adventure and chaos and
uncertainty,
and so that the very notion of a utopia
was anti human because we're not built
for static utopia.
We're built for a dynamic situation
where there's demands placed on us and
we're the optimal amount of uncertainty.
Well,
we know what happened in the 20th
century as a consequence of the
widespread promulgation of Utopian
schemes,
and what happened was a ham on a scale
that had never been matched in the
entire history of humanity,
and that's really saying something
because there was plenty of mayhem
before the 20th century.
I guess there wasn't as much industrial
clout behind it.